cuando vemos fotografías o vídeos de los
astronautas en órbita o en el espacio
pareciera que no existe la gravedad nada
está cayendo en una sola dirección no
queda claro dónde es arriba o abajo y
todo parece flotar pero la realidad es
que estos astronautas no se encuentran
tan lejos de un objeto muy masivo
por ejemplo este objeto masivo la tierra
si nosotros ubicaremos más o menos la
altura en la que se encuentra el
transbordador espacial sería más o menos
por acá
como ven realmente no es una distancia
muy
diferente de la que hay entre el centro
de la tierra y la superficie si nosotros
vemos el centro de la tierra más o menos
por acá
la distancia entre este centro de la
tierra y la superficie comparado con la
distancia entre el mismo centro de la
tierra y el transbordador pues realmente
no es una distancia diferente y de los
vídeos anteriores hemos visto que la
fuerza una atracción gravitatoria entre
dos objetos esta fuerza es igual a la
constante gravitatoria en mayúscula
multiplicada por la masa del primer
objeto
multiplicado por la masa del segundo
objeto y todo esto dividido entre el
doble el cuadrado de la distancia que lo
separa
esta distancia es de el centro de la
tierra al centro del objeto en este caso
sería el centro del transbordador
espacial pero este como ven pues no es
una diferencia muy distinta de lo que
sucede aquí entonces mi pregunta es
existe gravedad existe fuerza de
gravedad
con los astronautas
porque las personas del transbordador
espacial están flotando así y la
respuesta es que sí sí hay gravedad en
el espacio y de hecho estas personas
están cayendo pero el transbordador
espacial se está moviendo tan rápido que
nunca alcanza a caer oa tocar la tierra
como es esto por ejemplo vamos a
imaginarnos que yo me encuentro
aquí en esta parte de áfrica
y él lanzó algo con mucha velocidad con
mucha fuerza en un ángulo más o menos de
45 grados lo lanzo se eleva un poco y
cae de hecho esta es pues un lanzamiento
bastante bueno son unos
miles de kilómetros de diferencia aquí
entonces este baratos y lo lanzó con
mucha fuerza si yo lanzo algo con mucha
mayor velocidad
y bueno voy a lanzar
va a describir un arco y va a caer lo
mismo si ahora aumento esa velocidad de
la fuerza con la que estoy lanzando el
objeto
el objeto va a alejarse un poco más y va
a volver a caer ya que ustedes se pueden
dar una idea de qué es lo que les quiero
explicar si igual lanzo otro objeto con
mayor fuerza va a caer aquí
si yo llego sigo incrementando la fuerza
con la que estoy lanzando algo va a
llegar un momento en el que va a tomar
alguna velocidad específica que hace que
este objeto salga
y nunca vuelva a caer tiene manteniendo
una velocidad
de manera que si os es tan veloz que no
alcanza a caer en la tierra bueno no
sigue esta ruta tan extraña que estoy
haciendo esto es debido a mi mal pulso
sin embargo aquí lo que les quiero
mostrar es que un objeto con la
velocidad suficiente va a entrar en
órbita va a estar dando vueltas
alrededor de la tierra y no va a caer y
eso es lo que pasa con los astronautas
en el transbordador espacial
si no hubiera gravedad en lo absoluto en
lugar de estar girando estos al momento
de lanzarlo saldría en línea recta
disparado lejos de la tierra pero lo que
está pasando es que la gravedad sigue
actuando de manera que nos están
jalando o atrayendo esta ruta hacia el
centro de la tierra y es por eso que
está en órbita o está girando alrededor
de la tierra si el transbordador
espacial por ejemplo en este punto
frenará por completo dejará de estar a
la velocidad que tiene se desplomarían
inmediatamente hacia la tierra
entonces bueno esta es la respuesta
existe gravedad pero van a una velocidad
tan rápida que nunca alcanzan a caer a
la tierra y si ustedes quisieran simular
o sentir cómo se siente la ingravidez
hay una manera y de hecho esta manera es
lo que la nasa hace usan un avión que le
llaman el avión del vómito pues es común
que la gente a bordo de este avión se
sienta enferma este avión lo que hace es
que bueno si estamos vamos a dibujar más
o menos por acá
esta es la tierra o la superficie del
suelo lo que hace el avión es que
despega
sube y después se deja caer como un
proyectil en caída libre entonces las
personas que están a bordo de este avión
experimentan la caída libre que es la
caída libre bueno si ustedes han saltado
de un bong y un paracaídas o incluso si
se han subido alguna montaña rusa
esa sensación cuando llegan en la parte
de hasta arriba de la montaña y se deja
caer en la que esa sensación en la que
el estómago pues se siente medio mal es
exactamente la misma sensación que
tienen los astronautas
en órbita
o las personas que están a bordo de este
avión del vómito
y esta sensación
en el estómago es la misma que ustedes
tendrían si ustedes encontraran en el
espacio frutos profundo flotando lejos
de cualquier objeto masivo
espero que esto aclara un poco las cosas
para una persona dentro de un
transbordador sin ventanas alguna no
sentiría la diferencia de si está
orbitando algo o si se encuentra en el
espacio profundo es exactamente la misma
sensación